[Música]
y
construido en las alturas denunció en la
red
el oír a el castillo de los condes del
perro este monumento milenario es hoy en
día el principal testigo de la riqueza
de la historia local
bajo este ángulo usted puede ver todas
las etapas históricas del castillo desde
el gran torreón cuadrado que fue
construido en 1.030 y es el torreón de
piedra más viejo de europa también uno
de los más altos puesto que tiene 30
metros de alto es el torreón de los
condes del ph donde vivía y la morada
renacimiento que fue construida por los
príncipes de borbón y el chalé que el
duque de sulim el ministro de hendry
cuarto hizo construir a su lado
desde hace dos años este castillo fuerte
fue transformado en museo
los 400 objetos y documentos que están
almacenados ahí
les permiten a los visitantes recordar
los 1000 años de historia del monumento
y de la región
entre estos archivos se encuentra este
libro excepcional del siglo 16
de referencia al derecho consuetudinario
del perro antes de la revolución
en 1556 en este libro fueron consignados
en pergamino con adornos los textos de
leyes las costumbres de la provincia del
persa desde la edad media
este valioso manuscrito fue comprado por
5.000 euros en internet en 2004 por la
ciudad televisión le retuvo una suma
importante para la ciudad que el alcalde
no se arrepiente de haber gastado porque
este libro es único en su género
es de hecho uno de los primeros
documentos jurídicos escrito en francés
porque diez años antes en el edicto de
biliar cotero françois primero había
impuesto la redacción de todos los
textos legislativos en lenguas de usanza
para permitirles a todos los franceses
comprender el derecho que les será
impuesto mientras que el latín estaba
reservado para las letras iniciales que
están en un estilo italianizante en el
estilo manierista que era importado de
italia en los años 1550 dorado con oro
fino
otro documento importante conservado en
el castillo el testamento de rachel de
coche y la duquesa de sully y mujer del
principal ministro de henri cuarto ella
quien era perchero ahora de nacimiento
adquirió tierras en el parche sin cesar
durante toda su vida en su hogar le
enumera a su marido en las diferentes
páginas todos los bienes que desean
legar a su hijo y concluye tal como
sucedía con frecuencia en los
testamentos del antiguo régimen para mis
hijas de ruin y la marquesa de mir púa
les pido contentarse con lo que tienen
del matrimonio fueron ampliamente
dotadas es la ley del antiguo régimen
antes de la revolución todo para los
hombres todo para los hombres y las
mujeres sólo quedan con lo que se les da
el día de su matrimonio
para hacer viajar en el tiempo a los
visitantes el museo le apuesta también a
las tecnologías modernas
una tableta ofrece también la
posibilidad de vivir una aventura en
realidad aumentada
ante el interés de la realidad aumentada
es que podamos reconstituir sumergirse
en el torreón tal como estaba aquí en
especial en 1990 cuando tuvo lugar la
negociación del encuentro entre richard
gere de lyon y philippe auguste
a ellos les permite a los visitantes
poder descubrir de manera lúdica el
castillo bajo diferentes ángulos está
también la especificidad hay un
recorrido para los niños enfocado en los
juegos hay un juego de geocaching en el
castillo hay que descubrir un escondite
que le permite acceder a un código para
tener acceso a la siguiente parte de
recorrido
me parece muy bien re constituido porque
estamos acostumbrados a una
reconstitución en los libros es nuevo y
tiene un efecto creo
viajar en el tiempo hasta la época
moderna es el increíble destino que
conoció uno de los emblemas de la región
el percherón
y la raza persona nació en unión le
retrucó y sus orígenes son las primeras
cruzadas y con el paso de los siglos
esta raza fue mejorada y de caballos de
guerra también se volvieron caballos de
tiro
en 1880 este caballo de excepción es
implantado en las grandes sabanas de
américa del norte para trabajos
agrícolas
es la edad de oro del perchero
los estadounidenses siguen usándolos
este caballo fue comprado por un criador
estadounidense durante el primer
concurso hípico perdieron en francia de
hecho los estadounidenses eran muy
esperados en el ciclo 19 era una fiesta
en oyón le retrucó cuando llegue
para hacer de su castillo uno de los
lugares culturales inevitables de la
región la ciudad de nacional y el estado
invirtieron cerca de 240.000 euros
una suma que esperan amortizar durante
los próximos años atrayendo cada vez más
visitantes